well the president flies to Paris today
to meet world leaders marking the 100th
anniversary of the end of World War one
he's leaving the US while Democrats call
for an investigation of the forced
resignation of Attorney General Jeff
Sessions Face the Nation moderator and
Mama Margaret Brennan is with us from
Washington where she returns to hosting
the Sunday Margaret great to see you
welcome back
we hope Eamon does not hate us for
taking his mom away from him this
morning to come in and talk to us about
your second favorite job and there's a
picture of him he's so beautiful oh
thank you so much yeah he's just 2
months old so I think we can count him
as one of the younger viewers of Face
the Nation well we love him watching and
obviously you come back to a lot of news
what are you gonna be focusing on this
Sunday I know did I miss anything
quiet three months well this Sunday
we're gonna talk a lot about who the new
chief law enforcement officer in this
country may be we have senator Ted Cruz
and Senator Lindsey Graham two key
voices on the Judiciary Committee who
will be potentially holding these
hearings and questioning whoever is
nominated to replace Attorney General
Jeff Sessions who was just forced out
but there are so many questions here
about just what will qualify someone for
this job and the president's eyes
because when you think about it Jeff
Sessions was essentially the president's
border wall personified he was
everything the president wanted when it
came to enacting agenda but that
original sin of recusing himself from
the Russian investigation put him on the
wrong side of President Trump so we have
to assume that when it comes to
selecting someone for this job that's
gonna be question number one for the
president exactly how will you interact
with with robert muller and will you
make his findings public so we will talk
about that on sunday show and it is a
big weekend indeed of news market
because the president is heading to
Paris to meet with world leaders there
what do we know about what will be
discussed well this is interesting
because it's supposed to be according to
the French president a celebration of
what can happen when allies work
together right defeating as they did
side by side evil during
war one as he has described it but now
you have the French president saying
Europe may have to form its own army to
protect itself against China Russia and
the United States I mean if that doesn't
tell you how our relationship with our
closest allies have deteriorated I don't
know what does
but this weekend the president will be
standing beside these European partners
will also have an encounter we can
expect with Vladimir Putin no formal
sit-down is scheduled but we do know
that they will interact there and
there's a lot to talk about in terms of
the u.s. withdrawing from this arms
control agreement the placement of US
troops throughout Europe and what may be
happening later this month when the
president heads to the g20 is expected
to dig in more substantively to those
questions of arms control and trade
agreements yeah all right a man's mom
there's nothing like hitting the ground
running
welcome back mark having a baby agrees
with you you are all moms and I have to
tell you how much respect I have it has
only grown for those who can multitask
yeah as you all do welcome to the club
group we're a big group but it's a great
group welcome to the diaper family yeah
we're good
Margaret good to see you